Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update speaking to gamespot the director
of Final Fantasy 15 said the game should
be coming out in 2016 in the words of
Hajime Tabata I can tell you that it
isn't going to be released this year I
think we'll be able to tell you when
we're making the announcement around PAX
Prime at the end of this month he did go
on to say that they have set a release
date and are proceeding along as planned
then Tabata dropped the biggest
indication of a final fantasy 15 release
date yet we can certainly say to people
it's not going to be 2017 it's going to
be before that square enix announced at
Gamescom that Final Fantasy 15 would be
getting another demo before the game is
released they showed off new gameplay
footage at Gamescom as well as a story
trailer that depicts events prior to the
main game our very own alexa ray corriea
broke down the trailer and revealed many
of the story elements so be sure to
check that out and for more Final
Fantasy 15 News go to gamespot com /
news